Great, I'm loving that the app now
has login functioning, but now what?
The app looks exactly the same.
>> Yeah, well the Firebase database
knows you're logged in but
the Android app doesn't.
And therefore it isn't
doing anything different.
So I've got access to this AuthData
object immediately when the user
logs in.
I"m just not sure what the best
thing to do with it is.
>> Yes, sheesh,
I'm just reading about this.
There's actually a couple ways you can
get information from Firebase about
the user's authentication state besides
just the on authenticated callback.
>> Interesting.
Tell us more.
>> Sure, let me screen share.
>> So you want to keep track of
users authentication states, and for
that there are several methods.
You can use a callback method,
an event listener, or
specifically retrieve the current
authentication data for a user.
You've already learned
about on authenticated.
With this method you can trigger
code as soon as the user logs in.
But sometimes you might move to
different activities in the app and
continue to need the user's
authentication state.
You can use an authentication state
listener, just like the normal Firebase
listeners, will tell you exactly when
data changes in the Firebase database,
an authentication state change
listener will tell you exactly when
Firebase knows a user is logged in or
logged out.
And when you don't need the listener,
you can use removeAuthStateListener
to remove it.
The getAuth method retrieves
authentication data for
the currently authenticated user, or
null if the user is not authenticated.
This method is synchronous,
which is useful when restricting access
to valid users of your application.